okay so so we've seen now our candidate
construction of obfuscation right we
took a matrix branching program just
reminding you again remember the colors
correspond to the inputs right there's
the first pitch is the blue input the
right input the green input and these
matrices always cycle there you know
blue red green blue red green so on and
so forth right and what did we do we
took the matrices we killian randomize
them we added these straddling sets to
make these these sort of puzzle pieces
which is the place at which we're
applying the multilinear encoding right
and then finally there is this little
alpha that we added okay so so far all
I've claimed to you so is that we don't
know any attacks okay let's see how we
how we can try to get more confidence in
security okay so the first thing I would
like to do is just rule out algebraic
attacks so what I mean by an algebraic
attack is an attack where the adversary
respects the multi linear map framework
right so the only thing he's allowed to
do when he has an encoding is add at the
same level multiplied across disjoint
levels and test 40 at the final level
that's all he's allowed to do aside from
that he has actually unbounded power you
can do whatever he likes but but but
those are the things that he can do okay
yeah they fit into the motility no
absolutely not no don't know they
absolutely do not in fact um these are
these are these are kind of generic
attacks that we're talking about right
now we will talk more about general more
standard notions of proof provable
security towards the end of the talk
okay so but I wanted to start small
let's think about algebraic attacks okay
first I just want to mention that even
these algebraic attacks these are kind
of generic attacks for people who have
looked at you know a generic Mumbai
linear proofs and
generic DD edge style proofs yeah I want
to ask so I really like the description
from the Jake is the tip yes yeah
preventing the attack of choosing what
did you have in the GG HR yeah it was
kind of similar but instead of doing it
at the level of the month leaner map
levels themselves we did it with these
um sort of multiplicatively we didn't
multiplicatively like it was actually
very similar structure but it was done
at a multiplicative level within the
encoding itself so at a very high level
the idea was actually very similar but
it was executed in different way okay so
um I just want to just as just briefly
mention that algebraic attacks here are
really interesting right in fact there's
an entire sub area of complexity theory
earth medic circuit lower bounds right
which looks at trying to prove that
certain arithmetic circuits cannot
compute certain functions right and
there are lots of cool open problems in
this in this area right and the kinds of
questions we're asking now are actually
related to that in fact in a certain
model not exactly the model I'm telling
you talking to you about right now this
is a no work with Eric and more in fact
there are some obfuscation related
security conjectures in this generic
sort of algebraic setting which would
actually imply a the analog of P versus
NP in the earth medic circuit complexity
scenario it would show that VP is not
equal to v NP so it's actually more
interesting than it might first appear I
think yeah
so it's modeling is identical to the
generic group model I'm not going to get
into all the details of that right now
but the main difference again is that it
has to support multi linear operations
right that there's a generic Oracle and
you can ask it to add you know anything
you like it can ask it to multiply as
long as there's a disjoint set for a
given element that is not being modeled
that's a good point that's an excellent
point so there are lots of stuff that
son Jim was talking about that we're not
modeling here and again this is just a
in this is like this is the initial step
because we want to first gain some
confidence and personally I think it's
very important for us to establish
confidence in this way because it's such
a new area right and we want to
understand what the limits are and what
the different freedom of actions we have
here are sorry we can also do that yes
there are there are various ways to
stretch to strengthen the model but
that's not what I'm talking about to you
today today I was one of them but a very
simple model where you know you can the
good in terms of a career handle you
know that the adversary can say okay see
this matrix entry here see this other
one here I want you to multiply them and
then the Oracle tests are they're
disjoint levels yes if so it says i
multiplied them and I give you a handle
for the for the result and then you can
use that handle and do whatever you like
you know that this is the sort of very
black box way of thinking about the
problem okay how is it connected to
automatic circuit complexity and VP
versus the NP um I I could say a little
bit more okay so what we're doing here
is them is most closely related to
multilinear lower bound which you know
run rather some beautiful results on
multilinear lower bounds intermatic
circuit complexity but if you extend the
model further which is what we did in
this in this other paper where you allow
the atmosphere to even go beyond what
you should be able to do in the multi
linear model but which is algebraically
feasible given all the representations
we have then
that naturally leads to a model that's
essentially equivalent to earth medic
circuit complexity proving lower bounds
there and you know the certain specific
conjectures that we can make that would
imply the people's EP is different from
BNP talk about the special related
security conjectures you mean for these
particular techniques for these
particular techniques yeah we also have
some moral arguments but that nothing
extremely concrete some strong moral
arguments actually to show that so any
algebraic construction of obfuscation
that meets certain sort of sanity
conditions that all current obfuscation
candidates do meet if you could prove
that they are vvb office skaters then
that would imply that vp is not equal to
the NP but there are some sanity
conditions and things like that that are
involved I was lying to you a little bit
there but I can tell you more more maybe
in person or Eric can also talk to you
about it on but but by but you know
there's good news you know anytime you
say hey we're like these complexity
theorists we should all start to feel
very sad right because complexity
theorists have a very hard lot in life
right and if we had to do what
complexity theorists have to do that
would be very bad and so the good news
is that unlike those for unlike those
poor complexity theorists you know who
you are in the audience you know you
know those poor complexities are is they
have to study or they're supposed to
study right the algebraic complexity of
natural functions but we're
cryptographers we get to make our own
crazy functions and as long as they're
useful they're good enough for us right
and that's really going to be critical
here we're going to the fact that we can
make our own crazy functions and the
craziness here will have to do with
these these jigsaw puzzle pieces right
we're going to assemble these things in
certain way that makes these earth medic
complexity arguments
easier easier to execute okay all right
so I want to give you a proof first of
all what do I need to do what does it
mean to prove that a scheme is an i/o
scheme so recall that the definition
says that if you have two equivalent
circuits cnc prime then the i/o of one
should be in this official from the eye
of the other right this is actually
equivalent to another way of thinking
about security and this is to say that
there exists an unbounded simulator a
simulator that runs in unbounded time
and that can make unbounded number of
queries to the circuit see okay so it's
given the circuit see only as an Oracle
it can make as many queries as it likes
it can write down the entire cruise
table of see in particular right and if
such an unbounded simulator exists that
can simulate any polynomial time
adversary that's given the option as
input then this also is an equivalent
definition of I oh ok let's think about
that for a moment it's actually very
easy to see why does this definition
imply I oh that's please straightforward
right because if the simulator has see
as an oracle or press the prime as an
oracle that's the same oracle right
these are equivalent functions right so
the fact that i oh so we were already
assuming that the output of this is
indistinguishable from i/o of c and
these are just the same and this is
equal to my ofc prime right so the fact
that implies i/o is triviality the other
side actually follows from this
observation we made earlier right about
with P equals NP so the other side is
just you know an unbounded simulator can
write down the entire crude stable of
the circuit and just construct the
padded minimum circuit right for this
call that tea and just run the office
cater on that and up with that right so
this shows that I 0 implies this
definition okay
as it turns out this unbounded simulator
definition is the easier one to work
with when we're trying to prove
algebraic resilience against algebraic
attacks okay so um how will we do this
what do we need to do right I need to
give you a simulator right what are the
simulator need to do the simulator is
talking to an algebraic adversary right
the adversary can build polynomials of
its choice right it's given these these
elements these encoded elements of all
those matrices right and it can take one
piece o get x 2 we can take another
piece and multiply it by another piece I
can do all these kinds of things right
and in that way build some arbitrary
polynomial if that polynomial ends up
living in the final level right in the
level 12 through k then he could ask hey
is this polynomial 0 right and the
simulator has to answer him before that
the similar does that do anything you
know he says hey I wanted to do this and
this is great you know you got another
handle these keep handing out handles
right it doesn't have to say anything
the only algebraic operation in the
multiplier framework that actually gives
something in the clear is the zero test
right so the non trivial question here
is how does our simulator answer the
question is this polynomial zero that's
what we need to do okay so let's think
about that again we have an unbounded
simulator so it can construct this
polynomial in its entirety right it can
look at every single monomial that
exists in this polynomial okay the heart
of the proof is the following because of
this straddling sets in fact you can
make a stronger version of straddling
sets that's what we do in the paper
would with more and eric we can prove
that any such monomial can only touch
matrix entries that correspond to a
single input right because if not then
these pieces wouldn't fit together right
you wouldn't ever been able to get to
that final level
and that's really the key so I'm right
again it means if I'm looking at the
monomial it's some elementary
multiplication that's led us to the
final level we know the only way you can
get to the final level is by picking up
all the pieces right that correspond to
a single input which means you've now
got a single input X that corresponds to
that monomial right so we can map the
simulator can map every monomial to its
unique input corresponding to that to
the monomial right okay for each such
input X let's think of P sub X to be the
sum of all the monomials that correspond
to that particular input ok so our P is
the summation over X of peace of X right
and again our simulator has to answer is
p0 okay here comes our okay just in just
a moment and we'll get to the Alpha
sorry okay let me suggest that listening
about a simpler question what about
piece of X can we figure out if P sub x
is 0 or not okay and that we could do
thanks to Killian right what we can do
is piece of X corresponds to a single
input we know what the product of all
these matrices that's just going to be
the output of that function on X the
simulator can go to the Oracle ask hey
what C of X it gets the answer it then
applies killian simulation to simulate
all of these matrices right it now has
concrete values for every single element
of these matrices it then just plugs it
in to P of X piece of X and sees does it
evaluate to 0 by the Schwartz if ulema
because this is a degree bounded
polynomial we know that with
overwhelming probability if this
polynomial is 0 polynomial then we'll
get the answer 0 and if we got the
answer 0 then
polynomial is a zero polynomial right so
here we use a short simple lemon in a
critical way but so far all we've done
is decide if P sub X for some given
input X is the zero polynomial we then
need to decide based on that whether P
is a zero polynomial right p is a
summation of all these piece of x's i
claim to you the only way that p can be
zero is if every single piece of x is 0
okay why is that it's actually very
simple and that's where this alpha comes
to save us okay what is the silly alpha
doing right alpha sub I be all it's
doing is introducing an independent
variable for every setting of the input
right what that means is that if I have
each if I have piece of X in piece of X
Prime these are going to be
algebraically independent because they
have some alpha naught in common with
each other right so as formal
polynomials they can only the summation
can only be 0 of each one is
individually 0 just by algebraic
independence right so in this way for P
to be 0 again just applying short simple
Emma it must be the case that each piece
of x is 0 because there's no way you can
cancel out this alpha 4px with anything
in PX prime for a different X Prime and
that is the proof that's the way the
proof goes of course most of the hard
work is here which I'm not getting into
the details of okay so this is how we
prove security against any algebraic
attack for i 0 i haven't talked about VV
this can be strengthened to actually
show vvb security as well but for I of
security this is what we need to do
any questions on this yes talking to
involve the shrub zipper you need to
walk about sufficiently large field
right yes which is you know we gotta
soak the multilinear maps it will be
perfect and then very efficient it seems
that you have to have some blow up which
is related to the depth of the circuit
of the degree of the polynomial this is
absolutely true yes we do need our n to
be a product of very large primes that
definitely that we need that in order to
be able to apply it to apply the short
simple emma here yes this can be
extended to BBB rack and BBB is not
possible isn't that a comment on the
value of the proof is not really meaning
anything so that's a very natural
question and it's hard to give a
completely convincing answer in either
direction here but my personal viewpoint
is that it is still very meaningful
number one just because it better be
true right if you construct a scheme and
it has an algebraic attack well then
you're screwed right so you know so this
at least at least as a sanity check it's
important to do this right the other
point is that what does a non algebraic
attack mean it means that you're using
something more about the specific way in
which you're implementing the melt on
your map and indeed there are
non-trivial attacks on multilinear
candidates which are not algebraic right
that has to do with some weakness in the
underlying mullen your map and that's
something that's not considered you're
just in the same way as any generic
Rufus right so my point is this the
weaknesses that are there in this model
I think have more to do with the
weaknesses that are always there in
generic models rather than having to do
with this actual apparent contradiction
because that apparent contradiction just
has to do with the bit level encoding of
the of the of the muffler of the of
these of these included elements
but yeah it's like think of random
Oracle model so we know there it's not
it's only meaningful random walk we have
examples where you have secured you read
more tomorrow but the skin is broken
still having proofs and random Oracle
model are not useless that's that's
that's an excellent analogy that's what
I I think that's really right because
again there we have negative results as
well right for certain functions yeah
you know political groups for any
generic attacks that's why we are
confident one reasonably comfortable
assuming the generic group model right
well hold on so again do it just to be
clear that's actually in false so for
elliptic curve groups there's been a
whole you know research industry over
the past several decades where there
were proposed elliptic curves for
pairings that turned out to be not
secure because of these kinds of attacks
the point is with multilinear maps right
now you know the best of that's not
exactly just like CLT 15 right so in
multilinear maps has of May nineteenth
2015 at whatever time it is right now
there are no non generic attacks known
right so the point is that that's where
we are and we want to be in a better
place but that's where we are right now
thank you yeah
right and then of course there's a
philosophical point anytime you have a
proof you understand something better I
think this proof helps you understand
what's going on and that's why
fundamentally whether it's true or false
we you know we whether the thing
actually exists or not it does exist in
this generic model right that's a
mathematical statement that we can be
proud of and go home and get some good
sleep regardless of whether it's broken
in real life so all right so okay so
that is a lubricant security in this
proof in many places but that's not
essential so we can get a vivir proof
which means it can be all polynomial
time but the way that I described it I
wanted the the simulator to consider
every single monomial right I wanted him
to take the polynomial P and unravel it
as a sum summation of 2 to the N
different polynomials right so I was
using it in many different different
ways in that way if you cut it actually
is this this step right here that that
you have to make that effective you have
to be able to take a polynomial of a
dress remade and extract out the input
from it it can be done we did it in
gives you keep yes and
in other settings as well so i just
wanted to cover that tandem erected more
than generic modern holy stuff is really
it's a impossibility results for the
kick panel yes right exactly yeah that's
yes that's it as an excellent way of
thinking about this yeah right right and
here also you have to find some weakness
in the multi linear map implementation
intuitively which is what people have
been doing and what we should all be
doing and all right so this is an
algebraic proof right of proof against
algebraic attacks what about basing
security on a natural kind of concrete
candidate assumption in the usual
goldwater mccauley sense right the way
that we all know and love in our in our
in our community so i'll talk to you now
about another result where we are able
to base security with a reduction on a
natural concrete conjecture this is
joint work with craig allison and brent
and this is this is the second in a line
of work well two persons the line of
work on building security proofs for i 0
there was an earlier work by pass stefan
talong on using a sort of uber or meta
assumption about multi linear maps to
build to build I oh but I'm going to
talk to you about this more recent work
so let me first just change our setting
all but actually to go more like what's
and Jim was saying earlier let's instead
of thing about these non-empty subsets
let's just think about these levels the
way that son Jim was describing them
right so now i just have level one up
the level cake just coming up in a nice
ladder right where each GI is a copy of
ZN okay and we're going to think of
these at this n is being a product of
many large primes okay this doesn't make
sense anymore there's no such thing as
disjoint numbers so here we go again
just to what Sundram said which is that
if
level I and level J then I go to I plus
J and it's only allowed if I plus J is
less than or equal to the maximum level
k okay so once we're in the setting now
we can describe a concrete assumption
over multilinear maps okay and now when
we're in the multi multi linear setting
where the level of multi linearity is
polynomial like something that's growing
with a security parameter then the
assumption will also have to have
components that grow with the security
parameter so all the assumptions are
take a little bit of understanding so
I'm going to go through it slowly okay
let's take a look at a warm-up
assumption where k equals 1 okay so this
is no mole seniority here i have a
composite end with two large prime
factors 1 i'm going to call a special
prime factor see another one I'm going
to call a distinguished from factor a 1
okay so i can represent any X and Z sub
n by its residues right x mod Z and X my
day 1 i'm going to think about it that
way okay what does this assumption give
to the adversary the adversary gets
level one and coatings of a random
generator of every prime sub group
except for see well there's only one
just our distinguished subgroup so it
gets you know an encoding of 0 comma R 1
right where r 1 just some random number
which is just a random generator on that
side okay um also it gets another level
one encoding which we're going to call
h1 which is just random in both r2 and
r3 this is going to the h's are going to
get more interesting shortly but right
now just random element okay and then
what the assumption is stating is that
it's hard for the adversary to
distinguish between an encoding of a
completely random element or a random
element goops sorry or a random element
only in the second subgroup
okay only in the distinguished subgroup
for those of you are familiar with
bilinear assumptions this is the
bilinear subgroup decision assumption
right just stated in this in this
language why is it reasonable well what
what can i do right I just have a random
generator here I get my my target
element I'm trying to decide is it like
this or is it like this if i multiply it
with this then you know it still looks
random if i multiply this with us it
still looks random so the intuition is
that it's very easy to argue that
there's certainly no generic attack on
this and and that's why we hope this is
a reasonable assumption again the
bi-linear analog has been a mainstay in
the bilinear map world for a long time
okay yeah this is that you are getting
both the generator and each one and then
you that one of yes exactly yes you get
both the generator and h1 and then you
get an element name T and you don't know
whether it is of this type or of this
time you CD with the generator with the
sea and in the second case no no sorry
this is not this is this is an encoding
right so i'm i'm i'm assuming that the
encoding prevents you from doing that
kind of GCD that would be terrible right
no no sorry yeah but the CR the CRT is
just my representation so I'm never
going to call it an encoding this is my
CRT representation but the encoding is
the M map the multi near app encoding
and you're absolutely right that is
exactly what we want to prevent it from
doing you shouldn't be able to do G CDs
within the vm map encoding ok and again
you shouldn't be able to write if all
you have are these generic operations
there's there's no way to do a G C D ok
so this is our warm-up assumption let's
see what happens when we increase the
multi linearity here so when I go to K
equals 2 now I have to distinguish prime
factors a1 and a2 along with my special
guy
see okay and I'm again going to have
random generators for both of my
distinguished guys r 1 and r 2 now the H
is get a little more interesting the
idea of the HS is that they're going to
be missing one of the distinguished
prime factors so I'm going to get h 1
which is missing a 1 H 2 which is
missing an a two-component okay we think
of these as our elimination variables
because when you multiply something by
this you eliminate one of the subgroup
components right but i'm only giving you
the ability to eliminate one component
and the multi linearity level is to the
bass the next level so again it's easy
to see in the same way that the previous
one was that this should be secure at
least in a generic sense okay so this is
the multi linear analog of this sort of
subgroup elimination as a subgroup
hiding assumption something that we call
the multi linear elimination assumption
again just to make that point clear
right I can I can now multiply this with
this right but then all I've done is
only a lemonade one of these two which
is already present in both right so I
haven't zero at anything that I haven't
been able to zero anything out that
wouldn't get zeroed out with the other
choice of tea okay yes listing for 111
both the box of 11 then this would
assumption would break so absolutely
we're relying on the on the ceiling yes
on the exact ceiling of cables of FK you
know you cannot go to k plus 1 if you go
to k plus 1 then you could eliminate two
of them and then you would easily be
able to distinguish so that's an
excellent way of just seeing like what
is it that we're assuming okay this is a
strong ceiling assumption
exactly yes except for the first
subgroup that's important otherwise you
would easily be able to distinguish
right yeah excellent okay so in the
general case we have a que level map we
have K distinguished prime factors but
we also throw in some polynomial number
of other primes they're not going to be
not going to really show up in the
assumption except that we're going to
give generators for them okay and again
these H is their random elements that
are missing a component in a fly
otherwise they're random everywhere else
and again it's hard to distinguish
something that's random in all of the
A's and the special IC or Jeff bas
without the special guy scene okay so
this is the assumption that we call the
multiply near subgroup elimination
assumption okay so hopefully in the
multi linear sends it's a natural analog
of the bilinear subgroup decision
assumption okay and I want to stress
that this assumption there are no
attacks known as of May nineteenth using
the the latest proposal the qur'an the
fealty oh sorry I flipped sorry about
that completely unintentional flipping
of names for the CLT 50 2015 proposal
for multiple maps okay but I do want to
make something important of make an
important point now that we're trying to
give reductions I'm not in as nice a
situation as i was earlier right I need
to be able to manipulate these objects
to get other end coatings that's my
reduction has to do right my reduction
is given something from the assumption
it's the muck around with it and give
something else to the adversary right so
here we do need to support we
randomization again CLT 2015 does
support it so that's that's the good
news for us okay
and now what we show is that under this
assumption we are in fact able to
achieve indistinguishability obfuscation
so how will we argue that I need to give
you a sequence of hybrid arguments right
that starts at an obfuscation of c0 and
winds up at an obfuscation of c 1 i'm
just going to give it explained as that
at a high level the details are fairly
complex but but i'm going to give you
the main idea of what's going on so
first that are super high level what's
the what's going on here we're going to
use several hybrid steps okay to switch
between c0 and c1 and the main idea is
to gain come back to Killian okay I
still want to exploit Killians
randomization to move between c0 and c1
1 input at a time ok so I'm going to
move from Caesar to see 11 input at a
time that means I'm going to have to go
over 2 to the N hybrids which might seem
scary at first glance where n is the
input size but again you know if we're
willing you know in for a mile or going
but we want us for this for the work we
need to assume a sub exponential
hardness so if we have our multi linear
subgroup elimination assumption we're
going to assume it to be sub
exponentially secure which means we're
assuming that it's 2 to the lambda to
the sea secure for some constancy where
lambda is a security parameter but
there's only a polynomial overhead for
the multi linear map realization ok once
we do that then we can just choose
lambda such as lambeth the sea is much
much greater than n right and this will
allow us to have enough security to go
over 2 to the N hybrids and still have
some exponential security left over ok
so that's our overall game plan and
there are some again moral arguments
that something like this is necessary
but is it something that we haven't
completely nailed down yet either um all
right so what is the overall reduction
strategy we're going to we're going to
again work input by input right so the
idea of the reduction is to isolate
one input apply killian to move it to
the other circuit and then isolate the
next input then apply killing move it
over to the other circuit then isolate
the next input and keep on doing this
that's the idea right so the idea is
that we're going to have only a
polynomial number of parallel
obfuscations okay which are obfuscating
potentially different of circuits and
each parallel obfuscation is responsible
for a different bucket of inputs okay in
the beginning this bucket is full it has
all 2 to the n inputs this is 0 0 0 okay
but eventually we want to use the stick
to make our way through it and they're
going to be two types of hybrid steps
okay in one type of hybrid will just be
reallocating inputs from one obfuscation
of c02 another option of c0 so the
program is the same when we reallocate
inputs we're not changing the program at
all we're just moving inputs from one
bucket into another okay this is the
place where we'll use their our
assumption okay
the second type of hybrid is after doing
many hybrid type one steps when we've
managed to isolate just a single input X
here then we'll ensure that those ran
those killian randomizations are all
independent for this bucket and
therefore will be able to apply Killians
argument and information theoretic lee
switch from an obfuscation of c0 2 c1
the fact that its information theoretic
is a cool bonus it's not necessary but
it's a something that's cute and nice I
put a star here because in the paper we
don't exactly do it this way but this is
what is going on and just to illustrate
this this is kind of the moral lesson of
this kind of a hybrid argument is that
suppose that I was implementing a
particular program in this way right I
take my input X I see if it's less than
equal to 37 if so I evaluate c 0 of X I
then check the theological 3139 but I
still just evaluate c 0x and otherwise I
evaluate c 1 of X ok seems like kind of
a weird artificial program right but if
I can prove that this program is
indistinguishable from this program
where I've just changed the threshold
from 37 238 we're both of them are still
evaluating c0 right all I did it used to
be the case that this part of the if was
responsible for 38 and 39 and now it's
only going to be responsible for 39 and
we're going to move 38 to hear that's
all I did but this seemingly little
change is actually sufficient that if we
can handle these kinds of changes these
little rearrangements sort of
obfuscation then we can actually
leverage this to get all the way to I oh
okay all right so how do we do it
so we start with our obfuscation right
the one that we've talked about before
okay and first we just make a copy right
so we just copy it over to another
parallel obfuscation I won't go into the
details of that but that's fairly simple
relatively simple okay and again these
are both obfuscations of c0 they're
completely identical right there's
nothing different about the two circuits
they're randomized separately but there
otherwise completely identical okay and
then in the key step what I want to do
is use that assumption this multiple in
your sub group decision to see it
multiple linear subgroup elimination
assumption to bifurcate the inputs right
I want to say that the inputs that start
with x 1 equals 0 are going to be
handled by this sophistication the ones
that start with one are going to be
handled by this confiscation and
intuitively I do that just by zeroing
out these matrices okay so if I can do
that if I can go from this to this right
then I have reallocated the inputs among
these two office k shins of the same
function right that's going to be the
key thing that I'm going to need to do
if I can do this then it's actually very
easy for me to carry out my agenda right
of moving up eventually isolating and
moving things over right because then I
could make another copy I could again do
a similar step and then I can keep doing
this until finally i have isolated one
input here right and once I've isolated
it over there then i apply Killian and
switch it over to see one disinformation
theoretically and now I've you know I've
got this isolated I've got another one
then I'll yeah allies like one more I'll
switch that over to see one and then
I'll just combine these back right using
exactly the same argument so in this way
it's sort of a tree traversal you can
just go you can pebble your way through
a tree with only a polynomial number of
pebbles and and eventually wind up until
you've reallocated everything over to
see one
and and that's the overall idea of the
argument does that make sense again is
it doesn't make sense that this would
only require a polynomial number of
buckets to do this because again we're
you know all of these steps are
splitting in half right the the inputs
and so this is still responsible for a
huge number of inputs right and we can
just leave them there until we get to
one of those inputs to isolate and in
this way yeah change one input from
doing c0 to see what exactly yeah all of
us just to isolate that one right that
one that one input which then we were
able to use Killian to switch it to see
from c0 2 c1 and we just keep doing this
dance it's going to take two to the n
steps but eventually we'll get everyone
over and we'll only ever have something
like 2n parallel obfuscations that will
be required to do this okay 21 yeah
formerly this transformation or
something that goes on basic form of
infestation to purification like instead
of talking about yes something I don't
know if you want to do it but I think
you can do this right yeah yeah that's
what I that's what I got at with that
example of the code right that you could
you could you could actually just write
it that way that as long as you can do
these kind of things then together with
Killian or an alternative to Killian
that just allows you to do one input
twitching you could use the ow you know
it doesn't matter but you can then carry
out this this this approach important it
is you only or the other part of the
application sort of today it's very
important right because if the office
case size grows exponentially with
within then it's trivialize it right
over look up table right it's essential
that the number of parallel obfuscations
is only polynomial in the input size or
polynomial in the original circuit size
but in our case it'll just be polynomial
in the input size so that make sense
because again we want the obfuscation
itself to be efficient right if it has
to create too many parallel office k
shins positions property in your
possession
yes sorry yeah these are these this is
what the obfuscation actually looks like
like at a certain point the obfuscation
in the hybrids there will be an
obfuscated ER that will output a single
obfuscation that will have all these
parallel obfuscations in 10 K and
looking ahead this will be like for the
you know these these different primes
the distinguished primes and the special
Prime and the other frames they will
correspond to these different office
cases this will be happening in prime
see this will be happening primate one
that's what happening like that so it's
very important that we only need a
polynomial number of them but again it's
just a simple Crete reversal with
pebbles that you need to all right so so
let me give you a little bit of a sense
of how this magic works right how do we
actually deactivate so let's not talk
about evac deactivating too so I just
have this one matrix here and I want to
deactivate it right it's okay from you
to deactivate it because i have this
redundant guy over here right he's
anyway obfuscating the same circuit so
if i 0 this out I haven't changed
anything right I haven't changed the
functionality so just at a very high
level thinking back to our multi linear
subgroup elimination assumption right as
i said i need to have parallel
obfuscations i'm going to use the primes
to do that right now what I want to do I
want to be able to kill that one matrix
right so it better be that this office
keishon is being done in the C sub group
right because the see that was the one
that gets zero doubt in this transition
right either T has something in the CSEC
report has nothing in the Caesar group
that's what we're going to use to
indistinguishably zero out one of these
matrices okay so we'll have the prime C
over here we'll have the other
distinguished Prime's for the other guys
that we have around and as I said we
have to use this T to create these
matrices right and the fact that they
would so remember tea always has a name
one component so this guy will never be
affected but it either has or does not
have a sea component so either that one
will be there or it won't which is
exactly what we want to do how do you do
the rest of it it's not so
straightforward it's a little
complicated but essentially that's why
we have these H eyes these elimination
guys they basically allow us to create
these straddling sets the missing
component is kind of related to the
Strada lling structure that we want to
implement to maintain the input the
security gets in been mixing attack yeah
matrix no longer there disappears from
the circuit what you really need it's
been replaced by a random matrix so that
no it's been replaced by zero it's been
replaced by actually zero yeah so when
the distinguisher see the signature can
see you know like the matrix 0 no so
what will happen right the thing is that
you'll multiply all these matrices
according to the evaluation this part
we'll still either evaluate to 0 or
nonzero right this part will always
evaluate to 0 because it'll have a zero
matrix but it's blinded by this one so
whether the output is 0 or nonzero is
determined entirely by the circuit and
not by what we're doing here that's
critical and it comes up in how we build
this so yeah you know once we've done
that again the assumption exactly tells
you that either tee has this component
or it doesn't which means that I go from
having the matrix there to having a
zeroed out right so this is the idea and
a key point that allows reduction to go
through is that the program's the
underlying matrix matching program that
we have for each individual prime is
fixed the reduction knows all the
programs that are being office catered
it knows exactly which program
corresponds just to the prime 0 exactly
which program corresponds to prime 1 etc
etc right so it's interesting that this
reduction actually knows everything
about the program being office gated
right the only thing it doesn't know is
that one little bit of information about
whether or not it's going to be active
on a particular input or not right
that's what i think is kind of cool
about this reduction and and what allows
it to go through all right so with that
kind of given you a summary of where we
are with respect obfuscation
constructions and security analyses
right now as different as you know
questions have alluded to you know
there's the other question of where we
want to be right so you know what do we
have right we have a candidate I over NC
1 that's what we just saw and again
there's a there is the CLT 15 candidate
map under which the assumption you know
is plausible and you know you will see
more about that in the fellow talk and
then made the stock at the June
workshops I'm going to take this
opportunity to plug the upcoming
workshop we can also do all kinds of
interesting stuff once we have office
keishon for NC one again as Craig will
tell you we can do all kinds of
interesting stuff but in particular we
can use it to get I oh right so we can
use io to get IO in particular Craig
will tell you tomorrow that once you
have i oh for NC 1 that together with
the learning with errors assumption
allows you to get I 0 for all polynomial
size circuits you can even go further
once you have I 044 polynomial circuits
and one-way functions you can actually
use it to get io for Turing machines as
long as there's a bound on the input
size that's the current sort of
state-of-the-art in terms of how far we
can go with IO starting with I Oh
Francie one with standard assumptions
and this is based on sequence of three
well not quite a sequence based on two
works that independently obtained this
result with bounded memory and then a
more recent work that got rid of the
bounded memory constraint and left with
only the bounded input constraint and
Brent will talk about that at the June
workshop
in fact we can even achieve constant
multiplicative size overhead so I
haven't talked about efficiency at all
in this in this lecture except for
polynomial time and it turns out that
there's a lot of inefficiency here okay
so all these multi linear
representations and and all these things
do incur a significant loss but
asymptotically we can leverage again
leverage io leverage these these this
hardness to even achieve a situation
where the size of the obfuscation is
just two times the size of the original
Turing machine plus some additive
factors that don't depend on the size of
Turing machine those additive factors
are two to the 100 something with me a
new but that's that's that's that's a
very conservative estimate I'm sorry so
buddy but it's better it's cool that we
can get asymptotically but you know
constant multiplicative size overhead
and prevention we'll talk about this the
June workshop right but of course the
elephant in the room is that these mf's
our new there these assumptions are new
you know what can we do about that right
and on you know what can we do about it
well as sanjam alluded to right
certainly one thing on that we can do is
just gain confidence in these
assumptions through an attack and
defense cycle right this is half this is
been happening now in the multi linear
map world over the last several months
and you know it's led us to this
beautiful CLT 15 construction and
certainly we have a storied history of
this in cryptography block ciphers in
bilinear assumptions over specific
elliptic curve families and many other
examples like that we could reduce the
small inner subgroup elimination
assumption to some nice or underlying
assumption right maybe based on some new
candidate and map where there is some
way of doing some other kind of
reduction that would be great if we
could do that
and then finally we can explore other
completely new ways of building I oh
right in ways that maybe allow for other
nicer assumptions right and this is more
speculative in the sense that we're not
sure what it could allow means but
there's been some really exciting recent
product progress here in a paper by
prevention and Abby shake that's going
to be at crypto and an independent work
of near and the note which ever shake
we'll talk about at the June workshop I
it was shown how to build io from
compact functional encryption I won't
define that for you right now because I
don't have to enough time but but this
gives a completely different way of
achieving of achieving io unfortunately
currently the only way we can build
compact Fe is the use I oh so right now
it doesn't make any progress it's using
io to build I oh but this could change
in the future because again it's a
different object and we can hope to have
different approaches to to achieving
this right so that's these are some ways
forward and I'm sure there are many
other ways forward that I haven't
thought of and if I have have a little
bit of time i'll just give you a little
ad for avi shakes stock at the june
workshop so how does it work how do you
go from compact fe 2 i oh so the
starting point is a pair of papers on
something called multi input functional
encryption we're in those papers we
showed that mi fe implies i oh ok and
what these guys showed is that basically
mi fe is the right induction hypothesis
ok the way you can do is you can start
with something more basic like private
key functional encryption public key
encryption these compact fe objects and
start the bootstrap up the level of
multi input nests of the of the
functional corruption scheme so you
start here you get em i fe 2 then you
get em IV three
you keep you can keep on doing this
until finally you get em ife 44 n inputs
which then allows you to get I oh and
the slide was shamelessly stolen from a
v6 excellent talk you'll hear more about
it than june and the compactness issue
arises in this level of iteration so the
fact that you can iterate this end times
is because of this compactness
requirement that is so all right before
I end my talk I wanted to just make one
general observation right so if we think
about the history of cryptography right
we've been incredibly successful I think
we should all be very proud of what our
community has accomplished no doubt but
what are we leaving on the table that's
kind of the question I want to ask this
is not just about office keishon but is
in general what are we leaving on the
table so what do I me that our table is
cryptography which for this slide I mean
hardness right cryptography is all about
real leveraging and using hardness so
I'm ignoring information theoretic
cryptography for now that's a that's a
not at all in raising their cryptography
is awesome and we get to use all those
cool tools like we just did Killians
tool was an information-theoretic tools
you got to use right but because it
doesn't fit in this slide I'm going to
ignore it I have no greater reason than
that but it's really amazing right what
we've been able to do we started back in
the 80s with you know some basic
assumptions DD hrs a factoring and this
beautiful world was built right with the
public key encryption multi-party
computation zero knowledge so much
beautiful stuff right back in the 90s we
saw this world and we said wow this is
amazing right what more could you
possibly want right and I remember avi
used to give this talk you know where he
really made it sound like crypto assault
do you know like they just so they start
with these assumption
we get these amazing results right but
then you know we got these bilinear
assumptions and we build more beautiful
things right identity-based prescription
a true based encryption short signatures
much much much much more right and we
got the Gentry's you know ideal cosset
problem and lwe which you know gave us
amazing fully morphic encryption object
right and now we have these nmap
candidates which are giving us office
keishon functional encryption and
[ __ ] where which may be okay anyone
promise anything on a cracker on craigs
accounts anymore right but there seems
to be a clear our team here right as we
go like do we believe that we'll be able
to get fhe from factoring oh I mean it
seems a little bit tricky right I can't
say for sure the answer is no but it
seems like maybe not the right way to go
right so our field is progressed in this
amazing way by looking for new sources
of hardness to leverage right and
there's so much room on this table right
or the reality is we know hardly
anything about hardness I mean of course
because we haven't resolved B not equal
to NP right so we fundamentally you know
very very little about hardness but but
there is all the space on the table
right and you know what else is there
well how can we how can we explore this
this is just sort of a question to think
about you know what's the right way to
approach this kind of question how do we
systematically explore the table of
hardness how do we identify new
interesting problems new interesting
sources of hardness and figure out how
to leverage to get even more amazing
things all right so with that I'd like
to conclude obfuscation despite amazing
progress that's still in its infancy I
think we really need to explore risky
new approaches you know go out on a limb
as we've been doing and get more more
understanding of what's going on here
I think if we eventually want to get to
something like IO from lwe we should
meet we need to take risks along the way
to explore what the freedom of movement
is here as I've mentioned before
efficiency does remain a major
bottleneck I haven't talked about it at
all today to to the 100 is a
conservative estimate on these additive
overheads that are required and then
it's surprisingly useful as you will
find out tomorrow all right thank you we
didn't cover the space of hardness
sources but there's no obligation to
cover everything or is there like
something beyond this last flower of the
station that we want to strap a great
question i don't know what is the next
big frontier right after off the station
i'm sure there are right a good question
but even for obfuscation right maybe
there are other sources of hardness that
we should be really looking at to get
off the station maybe multi linear map
candidates are not the right thing to
look at i think it's a more general
question of exploring and understanding
the interplay of hardness in the
cryptographically useful way same travel
there we go yeah I like your last slide
about how the fondant all the flowers
flowers growing growing boy
that's another way another way to look
at it is like we started like with
mathematics that was done before hundred
years ago we used to refer to that was
for factoring and computational number
theory at the beginning of the last
century barium which was why this like
the second half of the last century and
the feeling is that now we are building
on problems that we may be investigated
mathematically seriously in the next
century right right right right and I
think you know there's a there is an
aspect to which aesthetics have has
really influenced the evolution of
cryptography which well on the one hand
I am a very happy participant of that I
like our aesthetics well then it's
something to reconsider right is in a
search for truth how much should has
headaches play a role in guiding our
field so this is another sort of aspect
to think about the future yeah yeah the
obfuscation does not imply harness but
it's true he doesn t is it conceivable
that you could have it unconditionally
what does it imply it would imply a
collapse of hierarchy
and more questions
ok it's then oh so this something that
bothers me especially about your first
construction that you show it really has
nothing to do with I oh right i can
substitute any definition which is
weaker than BBB and i can show the same
proof for that well not exactly because
the profile grave was only for i 0 but
you're absolutely right that we can
strengthen that proof to make it work
for anything in movie that's exactly
what doll was asking earlier right like
why should we pay any attention to that
if you can prove v.v.v which we know for
certain cases is impossible but again as
al mentioned as and as we talked about
before similarly situation is there for
random Oracle's right random Oracle's
there are negative results right if you
say well you know if you're using a
random Oracle why should I believe you
at all right we know that random
Oracle's are impossible but nevertheless
we like random Oracle proofs some of us
sometimes but as a community we should
like them because they've been very very
very successful right so in a similar
way this gets at some understanding of
where the hardness is coming from where
security is coming from